the Trump Whitehouse has a real big
problem with leaks and leakers and this
includes leaks about the content of
meetings that were not for public
consumption
this includes leaks about Trump flipping
out on people in the Oval Office this
includes leaks about other people
fighting at the Oval Office including
one story about I believe it was John
Bolton and former chief of staff John
Kelly leaks about a lot of the nonsense
that's going on and recently it's been
about Trump's daily schedules which have
shown that Trump on a lot of days is
just doing nothing he has this so-called
executive time for all or even most of a
lot of days and hilariously chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney said just a few days
ago that they expect to identify the
staffer who is leaking Trump schedules
within the next week and literally hours
later there were new Trump schedules
that were leaked showing that it's just
executive time he's doing nothing other
than sometimes having lunch with Mike
Pence and there's sort of two stories
here one is just the hilarity of how
they can't seem to identify who is
leaking the stuff and it can't be that
big of a circle of people that would
even have the ability to leak this stuff
it's been months and they can't seem to
figure out who it is that's hilarious
and it just goes to the general
incompetence that we've seen out of the
White House then there's the material
significance of Trump not working what
we're learning from looking at the
schedules themselves is that Trump is
spending 50 to 60 percent of his time
overall and sometimes nearly entire
week's unscheduled with nothing going on
other than I guess tweeting and watching
TV so the leaks keep happening
Trump's responses to all of this are the
height of idiocy going totally overboard
in his defenses claiming that executive
time is when he's getting a lot of stuff
done after a recent series of scheduled
leaks Donald Trump took to Twitter and
said that quote the media was able to
get my work schedule something very easy
to do but it should have been reported
as a positive not a negative when the
term executive time is used I am
generally working not relaxing in fact I
probably work more hours the
almost any past president and as usual
the hyperbole is very very easily
defeated we know that President Obama
would read in the mornings he would read
in the evenings he would have briefings
and meetings he would often be up until
1:00 or 2:00 in the morning working not
tweeting Bill Clinton would make phone
calls in the middle of the night George
W Bush more of a morning guy would often
be in the Oval Office by 6:45 in the
morning the only late-night work that we
know of Trump doing is wasn't it when he
called Pat Michael Flynn at like 3:00
a.m. and said is a strong dollar good or
bad right Michael Flynn is National
Security Advisor who presumably knows
nothing about whether a good of whether
a strong dollar is good or bad wrong guy
to ask yeah and and every time this
comes up we get back to do we want him
working right like when Trump does work
it's either destructive for the US
internationally or it's to enrich
himself personally so I hope that the
leaks continue endlessly until everybody
gets fired from the White House and when
we go back to Trump's going to hire the
best people I think the meme was are you
doing that if you have someone this
close to you leaking such personal
information and it goes on for months
and you can't find them now it's not
going to affect his base as we just
heard right as we just heard from Bobby
Azarian this is certainly not going to
impact his bait base and executive time
is a vague enough term that maybe some
in his base will actually believe the
defense that he is really doing work
during that time but the most important
question for me is maybe in some sense
it's good that Donald Trump isn't
working much because of the damage he
does when he actually does political
things